das größte rätsel der physik ist wohl
wie sich teilchenphysik und gravitation
in einem modell vereinen lassen dabei
helfen könnte die mathematische struktur
der league gruppe r8 sie hat besondere
symmetrie eigenschaften und könnte eine
einheitliche theorie in der für sich
arbeitet quasi die theorie von allem
also die weltformel schlechthin ein
super aufregendes und mister großes
thema dass er mir über whatsapp
vorgeschlagen habe danke dafür und
herzlich willkommen bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr kein video alle
vorgänger und zustände im universum
sollen sich mit ihr beschreiben lassen
von den kleinsten dingen im quanten
bereich bis zu den größten kosmischen
strukturen überhaupt rund 1 us physiker
behauptet tatsächlich diese formel
aufgestellt zu haben
was kann diese angebliche weltformel
wirklich und was steckt dahinter
schon in den 60er jahren hatten physiker
und physikerinnen herausgefunden dass
sich elementarteilchen mit ihren
unterschiedlichen eigenschaften wie
masse und ladung in eine bestimmte
ordnung bringen lassen das sind die
sogenannten lee gruppen also vereinfacht
gesagt strukturen in der mathematik die
über besondere symmetrie eigenschaften
verfügen mit den einfacheren gruppen
können objekte wie kegel oder zylinder
beschrieben werden auch wenn sie gedreht
werden sehen sie gleich aus bei der
sogenannten g8 struktur ist das anders
sie ist viel komplexer insgesamt umfasst
sie 248 dimensionen und damit sind nicht
etwa raumdimensionen gemeint sondern
freiheitsgrade also die variablen eines
systems mit deren größten änderungen
sich auch die komplette struktur
verändert mit ihrer hilfe haben
forschungsteams dann im laufe der zeit
das standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik entwickelt
konkret besteht es aus der kombi von
insgesamt drei gruppen in denen alle
bekannten elementarteilchen und drei der
fundamental kräfte berücksichtigt sind
doch eine wichtige sache fehlt die
gravitation also die schwerkraft lange
ging man davon aus dass sich dieses
problem im laufe der zeit von alleine
lösen würde eben durch die entdeckung
die gruppe die auch die gravitation
nicht ausschließt doch das passierte
nicht und durch andere ideen für eine
einheitliche theorie der physik rückte
de 8 theorie in den hintergrund 2007
machte sie jedoch wieder schlagzeilen
und zwar durch den forscher anthony
garrett ließ von der universität in san
diego erfüllte die acht struktur mit
verschiedenen bekannten teilchen und
kräften den 20 unbesetzten punkten
ordnete er dann hypothetische teilchen
zu in einer computersimulation ließ er
dann die struktur rotieren die muster
ergebnisse zeigen an wie die zeichen und
kräfte möglicherweise wechselwirken das
krasse daran diese stimmen mit den
messergebnissen in der realen welt
bereit so lieh sie in diesem moment
explodierte mein gehirn als ich die
implikation und die schönheit dieses
ding sei ich dachte heiliger bimbam das
ist es beispielsweise lagerten sich
quarks um grawe elektro magnetische
teilchen und zwar in familien von den
drei partikeln mit jeweils denselben
eigenschaften aber anderen massen genau
so beschreibt auch das standardmodell
diese partikel wie sie veröffentlichte
sein ergebnis unter dem titel eine
außergewöhnliche theorie von allem ganz
besonders stellte liese heraus dass sein
modell ohne strings auskommen und es so
einfach und schön sei jedenfalls ist
sich sicher dass das universum auf
reiner geometrie beruht doch eines steht
noch aus und zwar der endgültige
experimentelle beweis oder zumindest
handfeste hinweise auf seine theorie
beispielsweise wäre das gegeben wenn der
large hadron collider bei genf im cern
diejenigen 20 partikel aufspüren könnte
mit der lhi seine struktur aufgefüllt
hatte kleinere indizien für die u18
metro wurden in einem experiment dagegen
bereits entdeckt ein forschungsteam aus
oxford hatte kristalle aus niob und
kobalt abgekühlt und zwar auf 0,4 grad
über dem absoluten nullpunkt die atome
lagerten sich zu langen ketten und die
elektronen verhielten sich wie kleine
stabmagneten und zwar aufgrund ihres
spins also eine art re im polster
teilchen und aufgrund dessen bildete
sich dann spontan ein muster als das
forscherteam
das magnetfeld rechtwinklig zu den
spinnen achsen anbrachte die
überraschung war groß als man entdeckte
dass sich die spins gemäß der symmetrie
angeordnet hatten warum genau und was
dahinter steckt das ist noch ein großes
rätsel aufregend ist aber schon dass
eben nicht nur ein mathematisches
konstrukt ist sondern tatsächlich auch
in der echten welt zu finden ist und
noch ein wort zur stringtheorie die
durch ihren glanz das g8 modell lange in
den schatten gestellt hatte
einige physiker und physikerinnen
jedenfalls sind der ansicht dass das g8
modell des trink theorie gar nicht
widerspricht sondern sie nur ergänzt
werden ja einmal ausführlich über die
stringtheorie berichtet bei der die
elementarteilchen je nach schwingungs
zustand verschiedene eigenschaften
annehmen sie schließt im gegensatz zum
eher 8 modell die gravitation nicht aus
allerdings bezieht sich die schwingungen
der strings auf bis zu 21
raumdimensionen je nach modell beide
formel zusammen jedenfalls würden die
relativität und quantentheorie zu einer
vereinen zu einer weltformel der
quantengravitation doch dazu muss noch
einiges passieren denn für die
stringtheorie existiert noch kein extrem
teller beweis aber dafür gibt es ja auch
einen hinweis in unserem video zum thema
existiert unser universum mit string
theorie bald bewiesen dafür hier
draufklicken und auch darunter unbedingt
drauf klicken
da geht es nämlich zu unserem neuen
englischen blick zum science und fiction
kanal draufklicken und abonnieren
wenn er mich auf englisch sehen wollt
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran